[MUSIC]
JILL DOLAN: Princeton Research Day is all
about demonstrating different
kinds of research,
from performances that happen
at the Lewis Center,
to poster sessions of research
that takes place in natural science
or engineering laboratories.
So, we're really eager to get a sense
of the vast variety of research
that students do on this campus
in conjunction with faculty
and graduate students and staff.
PABLO DEBENEDETTI: The brainstorming
started about two years ago
and it pretty soon coalesced
into a cooperation
between Dean of the College,
Dean of the Graduate School,
Dean for Research,
the Provost's office.
So it's been a wonderfully
cooperative endeavor.
And, what we're really trying
to showcase today
is a cross-cutting diversity
in many senses.
First of all, it's quite unique
for an event such as this
to include undergraduates,
graduate students and postdocs,
so diversity of ages.
Diversity of fields --
we have science,
engineering, social sciences,
arts and humanities.
So, all the aspects of
University research are represented.
JILL DOLAN: One of the things
that’s important about this opportunity
is that it gives students
a chance to understand
what it means to share
their knowledge publicly.
What we’ve done to kind of mirror that
here on campus is encourage students
to take workshops with faculty,
to practice presenting their work,
to think about the quality of
their writing with people like
John Weeren from Princeton Writes.
JOHN WEEREN: The workshops are designed
to help undergraduates, graduates,
postdocs communicate their stories
more effectively, to share their research
in a way that others can not only grasp
it, but appreciate it.
RYAN DUKEMAN: I think it's a really good
opportunity to get experience presenting
academic work in a professional setting,
and having that opportunity is something
that I’m really looking forward to.
[PEOPLE TALKING]
PRESENTER: .... amazing fishery. And
the reason is that --
This is Asia over here...
ELISE FREEMAN: I'm a freshman.
I'm listening to these excellent
science presentations that I have no idea
what they’re about and I'm finding that
I'm walking away very interested
and very engaged, even though
I'm not directly involved with the fields
that the research is being done in.
I think that's the main point of Princeton
Research Day, is to expose the student body
to all these different kinds of fields
that are completely different from
what they're doing and walking away
with a sense of the significance
of the research that
our fellow peers are doing.
DJ RASMUSSEN: It’s very exciting
to be able to produce new knowledge
that would otherwise not exist
had you not performed that research.
GRANT MURPHY: All scientists are
ambassadors to the general public.
And, science, depending on who the
audience is, can be really transformative.
And, the more scientists are
able to explain what they do,
the better that society will be able
to understand and adopt new technologies
and new techniques.
JILL DOLAN: Taking the opportunity
at the end of the year to do a major
public, very visible event
in which students can present that work
is really very groundbreaking.
[MUSIC]